كما تعلم أليكس، لا أستطيع الخوض في
تفاصيل الوساطة المستمرة
كما تحدث الآن،
تركيزنا الرئيسي هنا هو إعادة الرهائن
والسجناء إلى ديارهم ولم شملهم
مع عائلاتهم وكما قد
تفهم هناك  هناك الكثير أه من
التوتر داخل العملية نفسها
ولا نريد أن نتفاقم أه
أكثر ولكن ما يمكنني قوله هو
أنه في هذا النوع من الوساطة
ستجد دائمًا أه كلا
الطرفين يقولان أن
الطرف الآخر  لم يلتزم بأه
بالاتفاق ولهذا كان لدينا
غرفة عمليات كما تعلم لدينا
تمكنا من إيصال النقاط في
الوقت الفعلي لتحليل أه هذه
القضايا على الفور وهكذا تمكنا
اليوم من الانتقال من  لحظة قاتمة جدًا
حيث بدا الأمر كما لو أن
الاتفاقية لن يتم تسليمها
في هذا اليوم إلى الآن العائلات في
طريقها للم شملها مع عائلاتها
نعم لحظة قاتمة جدًا تقول أه
فهمنا لاتفاق الرفض هذا الذي
كان  تم وضعه وهو أنه
يجب إطلاق سراح الآباء والأطفال معًا، وقد
رأينا الآن إطلاق سراح عدة مجموعات من
أفراد الأسرة أه اليوم وأمس
كانت إحدى المشكلات
اليوم مرة أخرى لا أستطيع الدخول في تفاصيل
ما هي المشكلات أه  الذي كنت
تتحدث عنه ولكننا سعداء جدًا برؤيتك
تعرف أفراد العائلة هؤلاء
وخاصة الأطفال الذين يتم لم شملهم
مع عائلاتهم وعلى
الجانب الآخر كما تعلم كان لدينا 39 فلسطينيًا و
13 إسرائيليًا اليوم إلى جانب الأربعة أه تي ناشيونال
لذا أه بشكل عام  التحدث أعتقد
أننا نتقدم
بطريقة إيجابية هذا هو اليوم الثاني من أه
الحقيقة والقدرة على التسليم الآن
اليوم الأول والثاني يجعلنا
نأمل أن نتمكن من العمل نحو
اتفاق أكثر استدامة أه والحصول على المزيد من
الأقفاص  أفهم أنك لا تريد
الدخول في صراع متبادل، كما تعلم، لقد
قال ذلك بين الجانبين، لكن
أحد المطالب الكبيرة لحماس كان
السماح بدخول المزيد من المساعدات إلى قطاع غزة، كما
قلت في مؤتمرك الصحفي  في
يوم آخر، كان من المقرر أن تصل إلى 200
شاحنة من المساعدات يوميًا، وهي كمية
المساعدات التي تم الاتفاق عليها لشق طريقها
إلى
غزة، كما كنت تقول مع
التقارير التي
وصلنا إليها جميعًا بشأن الأرقام  من المؤكد أن الشاحنات التي
تدخل هي أقل من أه
حسنًا، وستكون دائمًا أقل مما هو
مطلوب لأن الحاجة إلى اللون الأحمر كبيرة جدًا
ومستوى التدمير
مرتفع جدًا ولكن يجب أن تكون مبالغ الجشع
موجودة وهي موجودة  وهو أمر
نعمل عليه مع شركائنا
في مصر والولايات المتحدة وكلا
طرفي الصراع للتأكد من
أن الأمور لوجستية جاهزة على
الأرض، هناك
الكثير من الأجزاء المتحركة على الأرض عندما يتم ذلك
يأتي للمساعدات الإنسانية هناك
والتي نحتاج للعمل من خلال
غرفة عملياتنا هنا في الدوحة
تعمل 247 منذ أن
بدأ PS الإنساني للتأكد من أن جميع
العناصر أه يجتمعون كما تعلم
تحرير الرهائن تحرير
أسرى من الوجود الإسرائيلي، المساعدات
القادمة من مصر، كل هذا
يحدث في نفس الوقت وفي
نفس الوقت نقوم بصيانة
ومراقبة السلطة الفلسطينية
نفسها